Bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte Dick, bitte Dick, bitte, bitte Dick, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, aber schön, dass du da heute nochmal da bist. Bitte dick, bitte bitte dick, bitte dick, bitte dick, bitte bitte dick, bitte bitte, bitte bitte. Vielen Dank an Michi für dieses fantastische Intro und natürlich mir gegenüber sitzt leicht schwitzend, aber geschmeidig, gelenkig, natürlich Stervan Estofanios. Und mir übersetzt Florentin Will immer noch mit seiner schicken Frisur. Sieht fantastisch fit aus, glücklich, geschmeidig. Stark übergewichtig. Du machst eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gute Figur gerade. Ich mag das gar nicht, das Oberflächliche. Das ist ein sentimentaler Podcast, der mal unter die Oberfläche geht, der mal wirklich wie so ein Skalpellmesser auch irgendwie in das Gewebe geht. Ja, aber um unter die Oberfläche zu kommen, musst du ja erstmal über der Oberfläche anfangen. Ja, aber da würde ich mich gar nicht draufhalten. Ich würde mich da keine Sekunde aufhalten an der Oberfläche, sondern direkt ohne Oberfläche. Mal erwähnen, wie schön ich das finde, dass du vor mir sitzt. Ich weiß, du denkst, dass du in einem Fleischgefängnis lebst und du willst dich davon lösen. Du hast mir gesagt, du willst weg, raus aus deinem Körper. Ich war tatsächlich beim Friseur und ich bin bei einem Friseur, bei dem man auch online zahlen kann. Das mag ich sehr gerne. Same, David. Und jetzt war es aber so, dass ich zum Friseur kam und von mir war noch eine Kundin da. War ein bisschen zu früh da. Kundin war noch da und die wurde dann beendet, hat ihre Frisur bekommen. Das war so eine drei Meter hohe blaue Marth-Simpson-Frisur komischerweise. Und dann meinte die so, ah ja, gezahlt habe ich ja online schon. Und dann schaut die Friseurin
so auf ihre Kasse und so, ah ja, das ist schon
abgerechnet. Und dann sagt sie,
ah, aber da war ja kein Trinkgeld
dabei. Holt ihre
Brieftasche nochmal raus und
gibt nochmal explizit Münzgeld
als Trinkgeld. Und ich
sitze da und denke mir,
Präzedenzfall, den ich mitbekommen habe. Präzedenzfall, Präzedenzfall, sie weiss, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich konnte mich die gesamte Session nicht konzentrieren. Sie ist das Äquivalent in der Gesellschaft unserer Schüler, Schülerin, die damals so gesagt haben, ähm, wir hatten noch Hausaufgaben auf, sollen wir die jetzt gleich vorlesen, oder wann? Furchtbar, und ich sass die ganze Zeit da und dachte, also wie gesagt, ich hab der monetäre Wert des Tinkels ist eh relativ irrelevant. Ich hab nur so, ich mag diese Transaktionen, dieses hier hast du noch was, das mag ich nicht. Stimmt so. Dieses, und dann kramt man das noch raus und dann muss die warten und dann, und dann habe ich kein Geld und ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich gerade im Geldbeutel habe. Wenn ich dann nur 40 Cent habe, gebe ich das dann oder sage ich lieber, nee, ich habe nichts, alles ganz schrecklich. Und deswegen konnte ich mich nicht entsannen, ich war angespannt, ich habe nicht, ich mache sonst immer die Augen zu beim Friseur, um zu signalisieren, ich möchte keine Interaktion und ich habe es nicht zugepresst, die Augen, es war ganz furchtbar, ganz unangenehm und am Ende habe ich gesagt, ja, ich habe online schon gezahlt, ne, tschüss, wiedersehen, schönen Tag. Ich glaube, es ist völlig okay, völlig legitim und niemand denkt dann, ah, der hat mir keinen Trinkgeld gegeben, was für ein Arschloch. Ich glaube, das ist so komplett gesehen.
Ganz furchtbar. Aber ich finde, lass doch
online Trinkgeld. Wie Ärzte.
Weiss man eben nicht. Das ist nämlich das Problem,
wenn dann Leute Trinkgeld geben und der ganze Raum
so eingefroren und alle Kunden
so, ach scheiße, okay, man gibt Trinkgeld.
Ja, aber das sagt doch aus, ah, da ist der Sonderfall.
Ja. Klar freut sich dann der Friseur drüber,
aber er erwartet das von euch nicht auch.
Wenn ich im Aufwachraum liege, nach meiner Schlüsselbein-OP, sage ich ja auch nicht, ach, Herr Doktor, hier, hier, der ist noch für Sie. Ja, ja, fünf Euro Schein. Ja, gut, dann kann ich das, zahlt das alles, diese Operation hat einen 2000 Euro wert, wenn du mir trinkst, gibst du da mindestens 200 Euro oder so. Nee, also du sagst, ich hätte den Termin da abbrechen müssen, der Frau hinterher fahrraden können, hätte sie ja in ihrer Frisur leicht erkannt. GTA-mäßig umfahren. Und dann einfach, Entschuldigung, Sie sind das Problem in dieser Gesellschaft. Ich muss sie entweder eliminieren oder bekehren, ansonsten ist die gesamte Gesellschaft gefährdet. Ganz, ganz furchtbar, mag ich nicht. Letztens im Restaurant auch. So, Bar oder mit Karte? Ja, mit Karte bitte. Und dann, keine Ahnung, wird der Preis genannt, man nennt den Preis mit Trinkgeld und dann so, ah, ich kann leider, geht leider nicht. Und dann nicht. Ah, ja, sie bringen mich in eine missliche Lage, weil. Ja, aber da bin ich in Italien immer in einem Problem jetzt gewesen, als ich da jetzt vor ein paar Wochen war, weil das sowohl immer nicht geht, als auch Trinkgeld inkludiert, als Coperto auf der Rechnung steht. Okay, aber ja, dann ist ja gut. Nee, nee, nee. Weil das Internet hat nämlich nach Google-Suche gesagt, man kann trotzdem was geben, bis zu 10%. Und ich denke mir so, Leute, wenn es jetzt inkludiert ist, ist es entweder inkludiert oder nicht. Aber wenn man noch was geben soll, ist das nicht inkludiert. Dann ist es irgendwie so eine Servicegebühr, whatever, kann ja das auch haben. Aber es ist Gesteck, das Besteck, also das Restaurant, das Gedeck, genau, das ist das Wort. Und das finde ich schlimm. Ich war jetzt ja an der Ostsee zum Schreiben. Ja, stimmt. Wir haben es in der letzten Woche angekündigt.
Die Leute haben eine ganze Woche gewartet,
saßen da und was hat er denn jetzt geschrieben?
Arial oder Grande?
Ariel.
Arial oder Ariel?
Das ist die Frage, ja.
Und dann habe ich da im Hotelrestaurant manchmal gegessen
und das ist wirklich perfekt.
Weil dann kriegst du am Ende diese durchgewetzte Ledermappe,
da drin ist die Quittung, du sagst aufs Zimmer bitte, schreibst Zimmerzahl drauf, du fühlst dich auch wahnsinnig wichtig mit diesem Kugelschreiber vom Hotel, dann schreibt sich dieser Kugelschreiber immer so sehr schön auf diesem Lederpapier, Leserleder einbanden drunter, schreibt sich so sehr schön, so dick auch so, ganz toll, schreibst einen Namen drauf, Zimmernummer, Tipp und Unterschrift und dann ist das ganze Nicker hin und her geben und ah, das Gerät funktioniert gerade nicht, ah, nee, einfach da dran halten, ah, nee, ich muss das Gerät gern Himmel strecken, unangenehm mit ihrer Zahl drauf und der Herr hat hier nur fünf Prozent Trinker gegeben. Ja, aber das kann ich gar nicht eingeben, so niedrig ist das. Und dann lässt man es einfach liegen und geht? Oh, diesmal war es Florentin. Diesmal hat Florentin eine Mail bekommen. Das kann nicht sein, mein Mailprogramm ist nicht offen, das musst du gewesen sein. Diesmal, Florentin. Das kann nicht sein. Nee, das kann auch nicht sein. Das kann nicht sein. Das warst du. Stefan hat eine Mail bekommen und muss sie im Podcast vorlesen, weil er vergesst hat, den Ton auszumachen.
Ja, aber ich habe gerade extra den Ton ausgemacht vorher. Bitolo, Einzelzimmer und Chefarztbehandlung, das Komfort-Upgrade für ihre Gesundheit. Spam, Vorsorge bis Chefarzt. Diese Zusatzversicherung deckt alles ab. Also das ist keine Werbung, das ist Spam. Aber du bist ja schon versichert, oder Stefan?
Aber da möchte ich ganz kurz, ich weiss nicht, ob es ein Gegenwartscheck ist, aber es ist eine Beobachtung. Und ich finde ja immer interessant, wenn gewisse Dinge als individuell wahrgenommen werden, aber man plötzlich merkt, jeder macht das. Und da ist es mir aufgefallen, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein neuer Begriff ist, Spinnnetzcheck oder was, oder irgendwie so in der Richtung, oder ob du nur apathisch trinkst, während ich rede. Und zwar geht es, wenn hier Sturzbäche in Mineralwasser gerade in Stefan reinfließen. Dabei mit grossen Augen an, was jetzt passiert. Und zwar ist mir aufgefallen, und ich weiß nicht, ob du mir den Punkt gibst oder nicht, und zwar mir ist aufgefallen, bevor ich getrunken habe, warst du bei diesem Satzanfang schon.
Ich zahle viel mit Karte.
So, das sollte mittlerweile ja angekommen sein.
Und es ist ja oft so, ja, mit Karte bitte dann biep biep biep biep biep, dann muss da so ein kleines Pac-Man-Level gelöst werden anscheinend auf der Karte.
Und dann kommt der Satz, was kommt dann für einen Satz von der kassierenden Person? Vorgang abgebrochen. Dann kommt der Satz, kann losgehen. Das ist mir wirklich städte- und ladenübergreifend aufgefallen. So, kann losgehen? Dass das kann losgehen, der offizielle Satz ist für jetzt können sie ihre Karte ans Gerät halten. Und ich habe das wirklich bei verschiedenen Gehörten, jetzt kannst du mir den Punkt geben oder nicht. Ist dir das auch aufgefallen? Ist das wirklich schon flächendeckend verbreitet? Also ich höre den auch häufig, aber vielmehr, und deswegen gebe ich dir den Punkt glaube ich nicht, geht es um das Signal, ah, sie können jetzt dran halten. Also um den Moment zu signalisieren, jetzt ist das Gerät bereit. Aber da könnte man ja alles mögliche sagen. Da könnte man ja Wamos sagen, los geht's, Karte bitte. Da könnte man ja unterschiedliche Sachen sagen. Und ich kriege auch ganz viele verschiedene Sachen. Okay, welche zum Beispiel? Nämlich was genauso häufig, ich gebe dir den Punkt, den Punkt, jetzt sag mal, nicht den Punkt Punkt, aber ich gebe dir. Ich habe einen Punkt, aber ich kriege ihn nicht. Du hast einen Punkt, nämlich, das wird schon häufig gesagt, aber genauso oft wird zum Beispiel gesagt, genau, jetzt einfach oben dran halten, jetzt einfach seitlich dran halten, also den Ort bestimmen, als wäre es nicht offensichtlich, wo man die Karte dran halten soll, oder sondern sie können, das kommt auch häufig. Sie können, okay, alles klar. Ich muss nur darauf achten, weil ich habe wirklich irgendwann angefangen, darauf zu achten und immer wirklich gehört, kann losgehen und da muss man sich... Aber wofür steht das, wofür steht das, das muss man da das? Warum ist es gerade gegenwärtig, dieses Begriff, der Begriff, dass kann losgehen? Nee, deswegen möchte ich keinen Gegenwart-Check machen, weil es nicht gegenwärtig ist. Klar, man kann natürlich sagen, war gelblos ist Zahlen und so, aber das hast du schon vor zehn Jahren bemerkt im Podcast, dass das möglich ist. Aber auch das möchte ich sagen, da möchte ich eine Hersteller-Einigung, dass man nicht wie so ein Vollidiot diese Karte irgendwo hinhält, sondern einfach flächendeckend gleich bitte, möchte ich noch sagen an der Stelle.
Ich muss sagen, aber da kamen wir mal alle Kritik beiseite.
Wir haben immer geäußert, die Kritik, man kann nicht oft genug Bargeld loszahlen,
Deutschland ist ein Bargeldland.
Ich finde, da hat sich viel getan.
Ich finde wirklich in allen Restaurants und so, ich fahre, ich habe ja immer schon seit Jahren,
bestimmt seit zehn Jahren meine, ich habe keinen Cash dabei, Strategie.
Ja.
Wir alle erinnern uns an das Portemonnaie und ein Münzgeldfach. Deine Klemme, deine Geldklemme, die mittlerweile nicht mehr möglich ist, weil du zu viel Geld hast. Aber die, eben nicht, weil da kein Bargeld drin ist. Und das ist halt so fantastisch. Inzwischen kann man wirklich, komme ich mit dieser Strategie, weiter als noch vor fünf Jahren. Ich hab was ganz Merkwürdiges letztens erlebt, ganz merkwürdige Zufall, weil ich habe es immer noch im Kopf drin, und das werden junge Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr verstehen, dieses Oh, es braucht Mindestbetrag, damit man überhaupt mit Karte zahlen kann. Was ja mittlerweile eigentlich flächendeckend raus ist. Also ich sehe das ganz, ganz selten noch.
Nur letztens habe ich mir einen Döner geholt.
Ist auch einfach Bullshit.
Es ist auch einfach Bullshit.
Es ist einfach reine Gängelung, es ist einfach reines Also es ist reines, du hast einfach ein heißes Stück Metall und So, das ist der einzige Grund, warum es das gibt, ja. Es ist einfach wirklich Bullshit. Ich habe herausgefunden, also ich kriege diesen Satz nur in Kiosks zu hören oder Spätis, um die Berliner abzuholen. Es ist Mindestbetrag erst ab 10 Euro, Karte erst ab 10 Euro. Ja, aber glaubst du nicht auch die... Und dann sage ich immer, ja, ich habe kein Bargeld, dann nicht. Dann sagen oft die Leute, ja gut, dann bitte. Und ich so, hä? Du bist so abgebrüht. Und dann sage ich, nee, ich habe abgebrüht, ich habe einfach wirklich kein Bargeld, dann muss ich wirklich die Kohle wieder zurückstellen und woanders hingehen. Das ist nicht immer eine Lüge oder irgendwie eine Gängelung, sondern es ist
einfach wirklich die Wahrheit. Was ich damit nur
sagen will, ist,
es geht nämlich dann doch,
da habe ich mal gefragt,
also ist doch unter uns,
Bullshit, ihr wurde einfach, und dann sagen die, ja,
wir haben so große, hohe Kosten,
pro Transaktion
müssen nämlich die armen KioskbesitzerInnen
zahlen und dann
verstehe ich schon, dass sie sagen, nee,
Dann ... hohe Kosten pro Transaktion müssen nämlich die armen KioskbesitzerInnen zahlen und dann verstehe ich schon, dass sie sagen, nee, dann erst lieber ab 10 Euro, dann sparen wir uns diese ganzen Kleinstbeträge. Aber es ist auch ein Fisch mit zwei Flossen, weil du einerseits natürlich die Transaktionskosten reinholst, andererseits motivierst du den Kunden, dazu mehr zu kaufen. Das ist ja auch ein schneidiges Schwert. Das ist ein Zwieback mit beiden Seiten Nutella beschmiert. Also das ist, du hast natürlich einerseits. Die Mütze hat zwei Seiten. Ja. Die Schlange hat zwei Köpfe. Der Fisch hat nur zwei Flossen, dann kann er erstens nicht schwimmen, zweitens. Aber auf beiden Seiten oder nicht, die wenigsten Fische sind asymmetrisch. Es gibt keine Fische mit nur
zwei Flossen. Oh, das weiss ich nicht. Aal?
Eine oben, eine unten.
Mehr hat er nicht, der Aal. Ich habe einen Aal im Kühlschrank gerade.
Jetzt, in diesem Moment ist ein Aal
immer im Kühlschrank. Das ist ein schönes Gefühl, zu wissen,
ich habe einen Aal im Kühlschrank, hängt der?
Hast du wirklich so einen Aalhaken?
Der wird ja teilweise, heutzutage
wird der immer weniger mitgeliefert, einen Aalhaken. Jeder gute Kühlschrank hat einen Aalhaken? Der wird ja teilweise, heutzutage wird der immer weniger mitgelieferten Aalhaken.
Jeder gute Kühlschrank hat einen Aalhaken.
Na sicher, klar.
Da muss man drauf achten.
Aber ich wusste nie, legt man den Aal über den Aalhaken oder steckt man den so ins Auge rein?
Er passt eben natürlich keinen Aalhaken, er passt genau quer einmal rein. Und da war ich froh.
Wow, das ist aber ein großer Kühlschrank.
Niemand will den Aal bieten.
Hast du einen Quer-Aal, aber hast du einen Quer-Aal oder einen Seid-Aal?
Nee, ich habe so einen richtigen Dialaal. Ah, stark. Auch so, den hat gar nicht auf zu klatschen. Ich kann das schon verstehen mit den Mindestkosten für Barzahlungen, aber ich habe letztens tatsächlich einen Döner geholt. Und dann gab es noch Rücksprache von wegen, soll ich noch einen zweiten Döner vielleicht? Was? Also will ich einen zweiten Döner? Weil es waren, sag ich mal, relativ früh am Morgen und es war so ein Vormittagsdöner und ich dachte mir, die ballern anders. Ich komme ja heute nicht mehr raus und ich habe nichts zu essen zu Hause. Soll ich mir nicht einfach noch einen zweiten Döner holen? Zweitdöner. Zweitdöner. So, und dann bin ich nochmal umgedreht und bin nochmal zum Dönerladen gegangen und habe mir noch einen zweiten Döner geholt, wollte mit Karte zahlen und dann hieß es ja, aber mindestens zehn Euro. Was beim ersten Döner nie zur Sprache kam. Ich bin dieselbe Person gestellt in selben Döner zum selben Preis. Gleicher Mensch, gleicher Mensch Gleicher Mensch, gleicher Dönermann. Und dann musste ich mir noch
zwei Eiran dazu bestellen,
damit ich überziehen kann. Aber du hättest doch einfach sagen können,
entschuldigen Sie, ich hab doch
gerade bei Ihnen schon einen Döner gekauft.
Stefan, wie lange kennen wir uns?
Ja, aber... Glaubst du, ich sag's so, was glaubst du?
Du wirst ja auch mal älter. Warte mal!
Das kann doch nicht wahr sein! Ich war doch hier gerade
schon im Etablissement und hab doch gerade
hier mir schon eine Fleischtasche geholt und dann lass ich mich doch von Ihnen nicht an der Nase rumschubsen. So, als ob das passiert, wenn ich sage, ja, ja, sofort bitte, natürlich möchten Sie noch mehr Geld als gefordert, bitte nehmen Sie meine ganze Brieftasche. So bin ich doch in Service-Situationen. Ich mache Ihnen Döner, nein, ich mache Ihnen. Soll ich selbst runterschneiden? So, also so bin ich doch unterwegs. Und dann ganz merke ich, bis heute weiss ich nicht, war es eine Gängelung?
War es eine ... In mir kämpfen zwei Krieger.
Sonne und Feuer.
Mein Fisch hat zwei Flossen.
Nämlich zum einen genau dieser unterwürfige Sub-Guy, der keine Lust hat, auf irgendwelche ...
Ein Problem darzustellen oder unharmonisch die Balance des Universums aus dem Gleichgewicht zu bringen. Genau, den Betriebsauflauf aufzuhalten. Und Neugierde, den neugierigen Menschen. Und oft gewinnt der neugierige Mensch. Also was passiert, wenn ich jetzt einfach blockiere? Was passiert, wenn ich die Handbremse ziehe auf der Autobahn? Einfach mal neugierig und das auf Serviceinteraktion überfragen? Das finde ich so spannend, weil dann weiss man ja relativ genau, was passiert. Aber so eine Frage in so einem Serviceetablissement zu stellen, da kann ja alles passieren. Und dann habe ich eine diebische Freude, weil was soll er denn sagen? Ach, wir verarschen die Leute, weil wir wollen manchmal nicht so gerne die Gebühren der Kreditkartenanbieter, bla bla bla z. Ich weiß aber, also bis heute weiss ich nicht, was passiert ist. Falls wir Dönerfachpersonal unter den Hörenden haben, bitte schreibt gerne, also ist das eine Art von beim zweiten Mal, wie oft kommt das vor? Ich weiß, es war wirklich einfach verwirrt, aber am Ende war es mir doch wert und Genau, wie Kreditkarten, ich bin heute auch nicht verstanden, bei Kreditkarten muss man ja manchmal eine Pinnlein geben, habe ich nicht.
Die ich auch nicht habe.
Die habe ich nicht und dann muss man die gegen, irgendwie gibt es was, wenn man die reinmacht in die Maschine, muss man das dann nicht. Ich sag's immer an, wenn's heisst Kreditkarte, ich erinnere mich noch, als wir in London waren, im Hotel, war auch Kreditkarte und ich habe von Anfang an gesagt, listen up guy, I do not have any numbers, I don't have any numbers, there are no numbers left, I don't have any. Would you mean numbers? I can't put anything in. There are no numbers. No, no, not for me, a guy, I'm a no numbers guy, I have no number. So if you ask for numbers, I have nothing. I am honest to you, my bag is empty, my numbers bag is empty, I have nothing left in my numbers box. So you have no money? No, no, I have plenty money. Plenty money? No, no, go, go. Dann ist es fine, plenty money ist fine. I can just not name the numbers, my mouse is not. You don't need to name numbers. No, good, then take the card, please. I just need the pin for the card. No, that's what I mean, geil. So, und dann Typ. Und der meinte dann so, ach so, ja gut, dann, ja, ja, ja, ja, so. Aber es scheint dann doch immer zu gehen. Viele Dinge gehen dann doch einfach. Irgendwie diese PIN bei Kriegkarten verstehe ich nicht, weil es gibt einen einfachen Trick, den ich jetzt leider immer vergesse. Entweder ist es das Gegenteil von dem, ist entweder das Dranhalten oder das Reinstecken oder das Leiden. Okay, eins von beiden. Das eine ist katastrophal falsch und das andere ist ein Riesenvorteil. Macht eins von beiden. Wenn sie in The Big US of A immer zu uns sagen, just slide the card, weil sie immer schon, ja, das funktioniert nicht. Das ist immer so richtig, weil in den USA immer, just slide it. Und ich denke mir, es hat noch nie funktioniert, we don't, guy, we don't slide. Wir können jetzt diese Charade, in Germany we don't slide, und die, ja, ja, just slide it. Und ich immer denke, ja, gut, wir können sliden, no slower, no faster. Und dann immer, hä, ja, es wird nicht funktionieren, ich kenne ja meine Karte. Ich kenne doch meine Karte. Bei meiner Sparkassenkarte mit dem Kölner Dom drauf geht dieses Slide-Ding nicht. Ja, ja, ich weiss, was meine Karte kann, ich weiss aber auch sehr genau, was meine Karte nicht kann. Dieser Magnetstreifen ist zur Zerde, Zerde da, der funktioniert nicht. Da ist nichts drauf, der ist mit Edding drauf gemalt, der funktioniert nicht, der hat noch nie funktioniert, der ist nichts. Geht einfach nicht. Ja, aber es gibt irgendwie diese Möglichkeit, dann einfach den Pin zu umschiffen, nämlich namentlich reinstecken, dann kommt dieser Bon raus, wo man unterschreiben muss, und dann behalten die die Unterschrift von allen KundInnen. Keine Ahnung, wirklich keine Ahnung. Nach wie vielen Tagen wird das aussortiert, ich weiß es nicht. Es ist komplett, man steckt fest. Ah, Geld, wann ist das abgelöst? Das leidige Thema Geld, immer mit diesen ganzen Währungen und so. Ja, meine neue Idee, habe ich mir irgendwann vorgestellt, ist ja Tauschen. Also wieder Tauschen. Das ist neu, ja. Pass auf, also, Tauschen war ja vorher die Währung. Dann kam Geld, hat das Tauschen abgelöst. Warum? Tauschen auch anstrengend. Man hat Dinge, die will der andere nicht und jetzt muss ich riesen Dinge rumschleppen. Jetzt ist meine Idee, wir schleppen nicht, sondern wir behalten alles. Digital gehört es nicht mehr mir. Also, zum Beispiel. Also mir gehört ein Aal dann, aber der ist noch bei dir im Kühlschrank. Es ist eine App, die heißt, sagen wir mal, PayBuddy. Okay? Okay, viel zu guter Name, dass das eine spontane Idee ist. Du hast da schon viel Zeit. Hast du die Domain schon registriert? Ich dachte, sowas wie PayPal nur, ist auch gleiche Logo, aber Pay Dude, Pay Buddy. Ah, okay, alles klar. So, Pay Acquaintance. Pay Acquaintances. Also, und ich sage mal, ich schulde dir jetzt 15 Euro. Ja. Ich überweise dir nicht 15 Euro, sondern ein Gegenstand von mir gehört jetzt dir, der 15 Euro Wert hat.
Dein Aal zum Beispiel. Also ich hätte Interesse an deinem Aal.
Okay, 15 Aale. Oder wer ist nicht, wie teuer ist ein Aal? Nicht so teuer, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Was kostet, also Stefan, du bist so abgehoben, was kostet ein Aal?
Ich meine, was wird ein Aal kosten? Ein Euro?
Ja, was muss ich denn? Was ist ein Aal kosten? Ja, du hast den doch besorgt. Ich hab den nicht gekauft. Den hat jemand gekauft für mich. Was ist da passiert? Ich hab den gefangen. Ich hab den in der Ostsee gefangen. Der hat null Euro gekostet. Ich weiß, was es kostet, auf einen Fischgutter mal mitfahren zu dürfen, um nicht schreiben zu müssen. Ich weiß nicht, was ein Aal kostet. Okay, verstehe. Naja, so, pass auf, aber ich überweise dir jetzt einen nicht verfallenden Gegenstand. Zum Beispiel habe ich mal die Statue von den Osterinseln, dieser Nachbau, den ich im Souvenirlagen gekauft habe, für 15 Euro. Den überschreibe ich jetzt dir. Den kriegst dust du 15 Euro. Wie, wie? Digital wie NFTs,
sozusagen. Er ist mein Eigentum, aber er ist in deinem
Besitz. Genau. Aber es geht nicht um
Besitz, genau, es geht nicht um
Standort. Der ist in deinem Eigentum.
Das heißt, es werden sozusagen
15 Euro dir gutgeschrieben.
Es verlässt
nie Geld mein Konto,
sondern mein Besitz verlässt
meinen Besitz. Aber wie komme ich jetzt an meinen Kopf? Wie komme ich jetzt an die Statue? Den hast du nicht. Du hast wie ein NFT. Du hast die Besitzrechte. Das heißt, du könntest den jetzt wegschmeissen, aber hast du Verwahrungspflichten? Ja, in der App hast du jetzt 15 Euro. Und jetzt kann es natürlich passieren, dass wenn du jemand anderem, sagen wir, 7,50 Euro schuldest, gibst du 50 Prozent, das macht aber alles im Hintergrund die App, die Besitzrechte von der Osterinselstadt annehmen und ab. Ich finde es genial. Es hängt nämlich an diesen Ureinwohnerstamm irgendwo im Amazonas oder so im Dschungel. Die haben einfach so einen riesigen Stein und der ist deren gesamtes Vermögen. Und dann teilen die einfach den Stein ein und dann überschreiben die Besitzansprüche an diesen Stein und sagen einfach so, mir gehört ja ein Drittel von dem Stein, ich überschreibe dir jetzt ein Sechzehntel von dem Stein und dann gehört dir ein Sechzehntel mehr von dem Stein. Den Stein interessiert es überhaupt nicht, der Stein ist der Stein. Aber das ist halt so der Wertpunkt so. Und alles andere dreht sich nur darum. Und das ist eigentlich eine furchtbare Idee, die unglaublich unpraktikabel ist. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Nee, ist genau das gleiche wie Geld. Aber am Ende hast du Zettel, auf denen steht ein Sechzehntel von einem Stein und dann hast du doch wieder Gewährung. Ja, aber in unserem digitalen Zeitalter ist es ja scheißegal. Das wird ja alles im Backend dieser App. Aber was stört dich genau an Geld, dass eine Zahl auf deinem Konto sinkt und auf meinem Konto steigt? Du bist abhängig von Währungsscheiss, du bist abhängig von der Leitzins. Der fucking Christine Lagarde und Mario Draghi.
Du wachst auch jeden Morgen auf und sagst,
ich zerfucking Leitzins.
Die EZB macht,
was ich will. Mein Geld schmilzt
dahin, aber hast du jetzt geschrieben an der Ostsee?
Oder hast du nur
prokrastiniert und bist mit Kutter gefahren?
Ich habe überlegt, was stört mich, warum mache ich das hier
eigentlich als Job?
Warum macht man einen Job?
Also Stefan wollte an die Ostsee fahren, um zu schreiben, weil er dort nicht abgelenkt ist und ja, hat das geklappt? Ja, es hat sehr gut geklappt, es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, ich war gerne an der Ostsee, ich kenne das da auch sehr gut, wie gesagt, bin da immer, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre meines Lebens hingefahren, weil das immer unser Familienurlaub war. immer, ähm,
bestimmt fünf Wochen im Jahr waren wir dann
da oben, ähm,
in. meines Lebens hingefahren, weil das immer unser Familienurlaub war. Ach schön. Immer, bestimmt fünf Wochen im Jahr waren wir dann da oben an unseren Orten. Ich kenne das da alles sehr, sehr gut. Deswegen war es ein super Ort für mich, weil ich hatte nichts zur Ablenkung. Ich konnte da nichts ablenken, es gibt kein Kino da, es gibt kein Museum, in dem ich noch nie war. Alles da ist gesehen.
Deswegen war das so ein guter Ort, weil es geht ja darum, einen Ort zu finden, wo man sich am wenigsten selbst belügen kann.
Mit, ah, ich habe eigentlich was beisseres zu tun als zu schreiben.
Okay.
Deswegen da oben hin, schön Ostseezeit gefrönt, beim Schreiben auf die Ostsee geguckt und tatsächlich sehr produktiv gewesen. Okay. Es war ein bisschen viel Druck drauf. Ja, habe ich mir auch gedacht, ja. Weil natürlich dann, man ist dann da eine Woche und dann muss man auch was schaffen und das ist halt ein Projekturlaub und der ist halt auch vom Gelingen her abhängig vom Projekt. Ja. Und dann war wirklich so erste Nacht, obwohl es mir eigentlich gut ging, psychisch, tatsächlich sehr schlecht geschlafen und einen sehr starken Puls gehabt. So ganz dolle Herzprobleme, dachte ich. Ja. Und dann auch so Leuten geschrieben, dass ich das habe, weil ich Angst hatte, dass man mich dann in diesem Hotelzimmer findet. Und dass die zumindest wissen, woran du gestorben bist, oder wie? Ja. Oder dass die Hilfe rufen können.. Ja, dass die, wenn die jetzt nichts mehr von mir hören, die nächsten Stunden slash dem nächsten Tag jemandem vom Hotel Bescheid sagen, dass die mal gucken gehen. Alles klar, okay. Also, ich habe sehr viele Leute Angst gemacht. Ansonsten, das war so ein kleines Problemhüppelchen. Sonst war ich sehr zufrieden, mochte es sehr. Ich mochte es auch alleine zu sein, so ein bisschen sich auf sich selber zu fokussieren, nachdenken zu können. Ich meine, bei dir renne ich auf die Tür ein, du bist auch gerne mal alleine. Ich mag das sehr. Und du hast jetzt geschrieben an deinem Erotikdrama. Richtig. Okay. Am neuen, also wie gesagt, ist ja kein Erotikdrama, es geht ja um die RAF. Genau. Und nur weil das Die Waffe in der Hose heißt, ist es kein Erotikdrama. Aber es ist... Ich habe schon mal erzählt, der Verlag wollte halt gerne, dass es in diese Kerbe steckt, weil wir kommen ja aus der Erfolgstrilogie Glocken in Dublin. Genau, aber Meinhoff ist ja durchaus auch eine aufgeladene Figur, die bei dir auch erotisch sexualisiert. Klar gehört ja auch zum Leben, Erotik und sicherlich macht es die Geschichte auch spannend. Das Ganze jetzt trotzdem Erotik, für dich da zu nennen, weiß ich nicht, finde ich jetzt wieder so ein bisschen ... Ja, aber du hast mir nur Ausschnitte gezeigt und die waren durchaus spritzig, muss man sagen. Ja klar, wie gesagt, weil es hat auch dazugehört. Das ist ja in Ordnung, das ist ja okay. Nee, das ist ja auch okay. Nee, ich meine, es ist ja Teil davon. Ja, absolut, ich sage ja nichts, aber es ist ja ... Ja, weil du wieder daherkommst. Nein, aber ich ... Ist ja erst mal ein Buch über RAF, du bist ja ein Erotik-Thriller. Das Problem ist ja eher, dass du unter Erotik direkt Schmuddel verstehst, was ich nicht tue. Ich sage einfach nur Erotik-Drama als wertfreier Begriff. Okay, wenn du es als wertfreier Begriff benutzen willst, dann würde ich sagen, ja, es ist Erotikdrama über RAF. Okay, gut. Ich fand den Teil, den du mir geschickt hast, ja auch wirklich packend. Also das war ja wirklich ... Packend, ja? Ja, also das hatte schon ... Ich kenne mich jetzt historisch nicht so gut aus, ob das wirklich von der historischen Korrektheit so genau trifft. Das hat ja auch in der Regel nicht alles in der Ostsee gespielt. Genau, und auch irgendwie die Smartphones und so, da dachte ich mir immer so, ist das ... Ja klar, ich nenne das Ganze Alternate History, ich habe das Ganze so genannt. Und sicherlich ist da einiges anders gewesen in der Realität als jetzt in meiner Visualisierung. Okay. Genau. Ist auch mehr Erotik. Ja, ja, ja, das kam gut raus. Und diese ganzen inneren Monologe und so. Und das war schon richtig gut. Da hat man richtig mitgefühlt. Ich fand's wirklich cool. Es war wirklich sehr schön. Auch wenn man dann so mittags dann so essen geht.
Ich fand das schön. Dann so raus,
man hat was geschrieben vormittags,
dann geht man raus und so und denkt
darüber nach, läuft dann der Ostsee
lang zu einem Fischbrötchen im Bude
und sich ein Aal.
Ich fände das alles besser einordnen, wenn ich wüsste, was du geschrieben hast.
Einfach so, einfach so fünf
Zeilen einfach so.
Und sie dachte sich,
gibt es Menschen unter der Erde,
Weil wir denken immer nur an Aliens, Aliens, Aliens und schauen in die Luft. Aber vielleicht sind die wahren Einringlinge ja unter uns. Und dann kommen die Zombie- und dann eines Nachts Zombie-Mail-Würfe kommen an die Erde und fressen, finden ihr erstes Opfer. Ulrike Meinhoff. Und du klappst dir den Laptop zu, schlürst am Tee und sagst, ja, doch, doch, doch, doch, das sehe ich. Es kommt doch zusammen, Stefan, es kommt doch zusammen. Jetzt erst mal einen Spaziergang. Und dann erst mal so ein glücklich zufriedener und Leute fragen mich dann so beim Mittagessen, um was machen Sie hier? Ganz allein und ich sage, ja,
ich bin Autor, ich schreibe an meinem Roman.
Und um was geht's?
Wer das an mir sagt, es ist so ein philologischer, spannender Text,
aber eigentlich geht's um Zombiefilm.
Haben Sie sich mal überlegt, warum in Zombiefilmen eigentlich
immer nur Menschen als
Untote erscheinen? Was ist denn mit den ganzen
Tieren? Also im Wald
zum Beispiel, das ist ja für so Nekromanten eigentlich quasi eine Fundgrube. Wahnsinnig viele Kadaver, Leichen und wir essen ja. Genau, und deswegen und ich... Ach so, dann erkläre ich es Ihnen ganz schnell. Also, die Sache ist, die Maulwürfe, die ohnehin unter der Erde leben, die werden quasi nicht begraben in dem Sinne, aber die sind natürlich in den Löchern drin und haben sozusagen ein unterirdisches Netzwerk, das überall hinführt. Und die RAF, die kann jetzt natürlich mit diesen Zombiemauwürfen sozusagen diese Netzwerke infiltrieren. Ich bitte, uns nicht mehr zu belästigen. Sie wollen nicht gespoiert werden, ich verstehe es total, absolut. Nee, uns könnte ihre Maulwurf-Scheisse nicht egaler sein. Ja, ah, Sie sind dann eher kapitalistisch. Ah, Sie haben Probleme mit dem ersten Agebot. Ah, ich verstehe es, Sie brauchen mehr Payoff. Okay, dann gehe ich direkt in den zweiten Akt. Danke, danke. Vielen Dank, wie war Ihr Name? Und da habe ich auch noch so gedacht, weil ich habe davor ein paar Leuten gesagt, bitte nicht zu sehr ablenken, nicht zu sehr euch melden. Das dürfte man nicht schreiben. Und dann habe ich aber so gedacht, dass ich dann wahrscheinlich eher derjenige bin, der dann so Leute anruft und dann so. Na, wenn er sich so meldet und dann so und die so, ja, was? Ja, nee, bei mir ist gar nichts passiert. Ich habe nichts getan. Nicht ablenken, nicht ablenken. Nee, bei mir ist gar nichts passiert. Bei uns ist alles wunderbar. Okay. Genau. Weil du angerufen hast. Ja, nee, bei uns ist, nee, alles super. Und ich habe dann da gedacht, ich rufe Leute an und dann einfach nur so, na, wie ist so, und wie so, okay, ist irgendwas passiert, will ich irgendwas erzählen oder so? Och nö, und bei dir? Müsstest du nicht schreien? Och ja. Und alle wissen, dass ich mich hier nur melde, um die Zeit rumzubekommen, weil ich mich offensichtlich langweile. Nee, war nicht so, keine Langeweile. Aber ich glaube, ich würde dann eher so diese ernsthafte Situation, und gerade deine ganzen tollen Autorenkollegen, die wissen ja wahrscheinlich auch, wie das ist, also mit Schreibdruck und so und Gedöns. Und ich glaube, ich würde das in der Richtung ausnutzen, dass ich die anrufe und sage, ich habe jetzt die Idee. Ich habe jetzt drei Tage lang nicht geschlafen und ach, zum Glück ist die Idee jetzt noch gekommen und ich dachte mir Zombie-Maulwürfel im Nazi-Reich. Einfach nur, um zu sehen, wie die reagieren, weil die können ja nicht sagen, das ist die dummste Idee, die ich je gehört habe, sondern die sagen, ja geil. Let him cook, let him cook. Ja, geil, das kann ich mir so richtig, weil die wollen dich nur motivieren und die unterstützen. Ja, das eigentlich stimmt, sowas bräuchts eigentlich mal. Ja, genau. Genau, das gibt's eigentlich noch. Ja, aber kriegst du dir was ganz anderes in deinem Film? Ja, ich dachte, ich hab das alles weggeschmissen und dachte mir so, weil es gibt ja bestimmt noch so alte Nazi-Bunker oder so, wo die dann ausgeharrt haben. Ja, super. Und die haben ja auch so Experimente gemacht, so Kreuzen von Menschen und Tieren. Bestimmt, die haben sie ja Maulwürftiere, so Maulwurf-SS oder
irgendwie sowas. Super, ja! Und wenn da ein Blitz
einschlägt, könnten die ja so, und dann wenn
die die RF und schlägt. Du erzählst mir seit einer Stunde
die Idee. Willst du das nicht mal aufschreiben,
wenn ich? Ja, geil, danke, aber du meinst,
das ist wirklich gut.
So, jetzt war die Verbindung kurz weg. Du meinst, das soll
ich schreiben, ist gut. Ja, ja, ja, ja, super, super.
Wirklich gut? Ja, ganz toll. Oh, das freut mich, dass du sagst, das ist gut. Okay, dann reinholen, das find ich super. Unangenehm reinholen. Hättest du das jetzt nicht gesagt, hättest du es, glaube ich, wieder verworfen. Aber so schreibe ich jetzt. Tschüss, wir hören uns. Ja, das find ich super. Das hätte ich, genau, aufladen mit Pranks. Ja. Du bist gar nicht so der Prankster, ne? Also du hast, glaube ich ... Doch, ich bin ein richtiger Prankster, klar, da werden die Furzkisten rausgeholt, da wird das Stromhand und diese Brühe, die Wasser rauslaut, ja klar. Okay, krass, hatte ich dich jetzt gar nicht so in Erinnerung als Prank. Scherzartikel-Laden ist mein zweites Zuhause quasi. Ich bin nicht gut mit Pranks. Nee, genau, du mit dem Aufkleber. Mit dem Nagel, ja, aus dem Mickey Mouse Magazin. Nee, genau, sowas sind wir ja richtige Pranks da. Da hat man schon früh gemerkt, die beiden werden mal einen Comedy-Podcast machen. Quasi die modernen Max und Moritz. Aber ich finde es spannend, weil wir ja wir kommen ja ursprünglich, haben wir ja unsere ersten Wir kommen ja vom Prank eigentlich, ne? Writing Jobs hatten wir ja bei Late Night Show und danach Sketch Show, wo man sehr wenig Zeit hatte für das Produkt. Das stimmt, ja. Dann habe ich eine Serie gemacht, da war auch ein bisschen Druck drauf,
aber ich bin eigentlich so sehr straffe Deadlines
gewohnt, unabhängig, ich will jetzt nicht
sagen, wo was es sich handelt,
aber in dieser Kunstform hat man
sehr, sehr viel Zeit.
Ah, okay. Und ich weiß gar nicht,
wie gut ich das finde.
Und dann, das war jetzt auch nicht die erste
Fassung, sondern es geht halt darum,
sich jetzt selber zu redigieren. Und das ist sehr, sehr spannend. Ich finde das wirklich super interessant, weil man hat das ja aufgeschrieben, weil man das mal gut fand. Ja. Und jetzt ist man gezwungen, ja, und dann es war auch spannend damals bei der Arbeit mit Netflix, wo die gesagt hatten mal, ja, super erste Fassung, wir freuen uns schon auf die zweite. Und dann waren wir alle so. Also gar kein Feedback bekommen, sondern nur. Okay, genau. Ja, super coole erste Fassung, richtig Spaß gemacht. Mega, way to go, guys. Wir freuen uns auf die zweite. Aufgelegt. Und wir dachten dann, ja, okay, dann warum machen wir da, drehen wir da sich einfach dran, wenn das so gut ist. Ja, ja. Und es ist ja, ja, nee, man macht mit der ersten Fassung nichts, sondern braucht dann mehrere. Aber klar, man soll das selber machen, weil es soll ja eine Voice sein und künstlerischer Anspruch und die Voice des Künstlers, der Künstlerin sein. Von daher kommt da nicht so viel Feedback, weil wir wollen die künstlerische Vision wahren, ist ja schön, aber dann, was dann? Das fand ich spannend. Ja, ich habe jetzt auch meine Sachen ausgemistet und ich habe mal einen Liebesbrief geschrieben. In der ersten Fassung? Genau, und den habe ich noch in der ersten Fassung. Die zweite Fassung habe ich abgeschickt. Jetzt war die zweite Fassung gebraucht. Genau, die zweite Fassung habe ich abgeschickt, aber die erste Fassung habe ich noch aufgehoben. Das heißt, da habe ich mich auch selber redigiert. Und ich habe noch mal reingelesen und gut, dass da noch mal jemand drüber geschaut hat. Also sehr blumige Vergleiche, sage ich mal, nicht wirklich auf dem Punkt. Schlüpfrig. Sehr, sehr schlüpfrig. Viele auch so Billardvergleiche. Ich würde gerne mein Kugel in eine Kugel Loch. Und ich dachte, weder sie noch ich haben irgendwas mit Billard zu tun, deswegen ganz
merkwürdig, warum ich mich in diese
Bilderwolke hineinbegeben
habe. Manchmal yes and, man läuft
da in eine Richtung. Oder manchmal
rollt die Kugel und man denkt einfach nur noch, wir gucken
wohin sie rollt und man denkt gar nicht mehr,
sollte sie rollen?
Wie funktioniert Snooker eigentlich?
Unsere Liebe ist wie Snooker.
Undurchdringbar. Kompliziert und dauert viel zu lange. Kürz, Löcher und undurchdringbar komplex. Weiss man nicht genau, aber es wird auch alles weggeschmissen, bekommt alles weg. Die ganzen alten Ideen, die ganzen alten Sachen. Ja, das ist die Frage. So alte Liebesgriffe, ich meine, man guckt sich mal an, man kann sich fotografieren, aber was willst du damit? Oh ja, gut, aber dann digital, dann wirst du natürlich gehackt, dann The Fappening, dann die Fragen nicht die Hacker, sollen wir deine Sexvideos leaken oder deine Liebesbriefe? Und dann hast du eine echt schwere Entscheidung. Das wäre ein Film, das wäre ein Film, das wäre ein Film. Ich habe den besten Podcast gehört. Oh ja. The Kill List. Und die Prämisse ist, da gab es eine Darknet-Website mit angeblichen Hitmen. Also du kannst Auftragsmorde bestellen auf dieser Darknet-Website. Ja. Und das gibt's ja immer so, im Darknet ist alles möglich, da kannst du dir neue Identität, Ausweise, Führerscheine, Reisepass und halt Auftragsmord kaufen.
Ja. immer so, ah, im Darknet ist alles möglich, da kannst du dir neue Identität, Ausweise, Führerscheine,
Reisepass und halt Auftragsmord kaufen.
Es ist nicht wirklich so und vielleicht
geht das, aber nein. Also diese
Seiten kennt man nicht und so und das ist Bullshit,
man findet im Darknet keinen Auftragsmord.
Aber diese Seite war sehr,
sagen wir mal, sofern
Darknet-Seiten authentisch und
seriös daherkommen können, haben die all diese Punkte, also alle diese Boxen getickt. Und das war aber ein Scam. Und dann hatten die, so ein Journalist hatte einen Hackerfreund und der ist in das Backend dieser Website reingekommen, hat also gesehen, alle Konversationen, also alle Bestellungen und alle Konversationen mit den Hitmen, wusste aber, es ist indeed ein Scam. Jetzt hatte er eine Liste mit 85 Opfern, die getötet werden sollen. Dann kam raus, dass eine von denen in der Tat getötet wurde. Aber es war klar, es ist ein Scam. Da kam raus, es war der Mann. Der hatte eine Affäre, alles schlimm, der hat dann seine Frau umgebracht. Und dann wurde denen so klar, okay, gut, nur weil es keine seriöse Website ist, diese Menschen sind tatsächlich in Gefahr. Weil Leute spielen den Gedanken durch, die wollen die umbringen. Dieser dann haben die, dieser Podcast geht darum, wie die dann diese 45 Leute abklappern und denen sagen, und die legen natürlich erstmal auf, wenn du sagst, ja, wir haben im Darknet eine Website und sie werden, sie wollen, jemand zahlt gerade 30.000 Euro, dass sie getötet werden. Und dann dachten die, die glauben das ja nicht, wie würdest du reagieren, wenn die jemanden sagt? Ich würd's glauben, ich hab viele Fragen. ich habe gedacht, wenn du getötet werden willst, von irgendwer will dich umbringen, dann weisst du das oder ich dachte, viele haben sich selber draufgeschrieben, weil die Angst haben vor dem Selbstmord und sich selber draufschreiben, naja okay, auch interessant, ja jedenfalls war dann da so eine einer der ersten Folgen so eine Schweizerin und die haben sie angerufen und dir gesagt, ja, ich weiss, wer es ist. Ja, ich weiss, wer mich umbringen will. Aber wie badass eigentlich ist das. Die war super badass. Ja, ich weiss. Und die dann so, ja, wollen wir sie, wir bezahlen ein Hotel, dass sie woanders hinkönnen. Die so, ah, nee, I'm safe. Will schon. Ja, und dann wusste sie, dass es ihr Ex-Mann ist, mit dem die gerade in so einer Scheiss-Scheidung steckt, wo es auch um viel Geld geht. Und dann wusste sie, dann hat sie gesagt, ja, der ist bereit, 30.000 Euro hat er gezahlt, um sie umzubringen, umbringen zu lassen. Wie peinlich, ey, wirklich, aber auch das Gespräch dann so. Du, Udo, ähm, pass mal auf, ich hab da so eine Nachricht bekommen von Hackern, und zwar mit der Website Easykill24. Und zwar, da ist mein Name aufgetaucht. Ach, klasse, crazy, wer will dich denn umbringen lassen? Also wenn die Website so funktioniert, also wenn... Genau, du hast es gesagt, die Website, ohne dass ich es gesagt habe, funktioniert die Website genau so, dass man jemanden umbringen lassen kann. Ja gut, aber das ist naheliegend bei der Website, also das ist ja seriös. Richtig, und die haben nämlich auch den Namen desjenigen gespeichert, der den Auftrag erstellt hat, der hat es nämlich einen Klarnamen gemacht. Wer denn? Ja, wer war das denn? Wer denn? Wer könnte das denn gewesen sein? Weißt du, was ich glaube? Dass da durch komische Umstände mein Name stehen könnte. Weil neulich hatte ich so eine komische Mail in meinem E-Mail-Fach, wo ich so draufgeklickt habe und dann dachte ich so, ah, jetzt wurde ich bestimmt gehackt. Weil die haben nämlich auch sämtliche Voice-Nachrichten aufgenommen, wie man da angerufen hat. Ja, krass, weil neulich hatte ich auch so eine Mail bei Wops at. Ja, ich meine, du bist schon sehr glaubwürdig, deswegen und dann hat da jemand wohl meine Stimme benutzt, heute mit KI und AI ist ja alles möglich, mit so Voice Changer, so Deepfake. Die Kreditkarte wurde hinterlegt. Ja, die wurde auch neulich. Was? Wirklich? Ich weiß, hier geht es drunter und drüber. Ausgenommen, wie eine Weihnachtsgans. Wie eine Weihnachtsgans. Die haben dir alles genommen. Ja, wie so ein Kö, wie so ein Billard, also um jetzt einen Billard-Vergleich heranzuziehen, wurde sich da einmal, also all in, also wenn man quasi einmal im ersten Zug alles ... Automatisch alle Kugeln rein. So wurde ich bei dem Tisch gezogen. Okay, ja, ja, ja. Mir wird es wie so ein Kö, einmal bei dem Kopf gezogen. Alles klar, verrückt. Genau. Ich mache ein Foto von dir, wie du das Geld überbringst. Ah ja, gut, ja, ich weiß, ich will dich gerne umbringen lassen. Aber interessant. Aber, also, wann merkt man, dass es ein Scam ist? Also sagt man dann, ich würde gerne, dass wir meine Ex-Frau umbringen, sagen wir zwei Wochen und dann sitzt du zwei Wochen rum und dann so, schaust du mal so ins Fenster rein, die lebt noch und du denkst dir, fuck. Genau, furchtbar. Und dann haben die oft gesagt, ja, wir haben uns noch hingekriegt, wir suchen gerade noch einen Hitman in Australien bei Ihnen, wir brauchen tatsächlich noch 5000 Dollar und dann kriegen wir es hin nächste Woche. Red Flag, sofort Red Flag. Alles, ich weiß gar nicht wo, also man sieht die Red Flag vor lauter Red Flags nicht mehr. Für mich noch eine Orange Flag, würde ich sagen. Aber wenn die dann über den vereinbarten Betrag noch hinaus wollen, dann Red Flag.
Und nicht im guten Sinne Mord ausgeführt Red Flag, sondern Schlecht Flag. Wir geben ihnen ein, vor allem das Problem ist ja, dass auch solche Seiten leben ja, und deswegen verstehe ich gar nicht, warum da 85 Aufträge überhaupt zusammenkamen, leben ja von guten Bewertungen. Auch Drogenwebsites im Internet leben ja sozusagen von den Jelp fünf Sternen. Ja gut, aber ist sie nie denn glaubwürdig? Also ich meine, da würde es ja keine klaren Namen geben. Brigitte Rubensbacher sagt, ja, die haben meinen Mann zerstückelt und in den Sumpf geworfen. Genau, fünf Sterne, jederzeit wieder. Jederzeit gerne wieder, ich habe noch Kinder. Und dann war auch so geil, einer hat so geschrieben, ja, lass es wie ein Robbery Gun Wrong aussehen. Ah, fand ich geil. Dass er ausgeräumt wurde, ne? Genau, Robbery Gun Wrong. Okay. Also Unfall, lass es wie ein Unfall aussehen, lass es wie ein K-Exzident aussehen. Und dann diese ganzen Conversations haben die gesehen, und irgendwann hat das Ganze, und das ist ja bei True Crime Fime-Fällen wirklich, also bei so True-Crime-Podcasts passiert ja
einfach nichts. Es sind ja oft einfach,
man hat irgendwie 20 Stunden zugehört und dann
fragt irgendwer, oh, wie ist der True-Crime-Podcast und sagt, das ist mega geil.
Was ist denn bislang passiert und du denkst
darüber nach und naja, eigentlich
die haben halt die Akten
die haben jetzt Akten
ein, ich sag's, ja gut,
du bist 20 Stunden drin.
Die haben jetzt den Ort rausgefunden, wo der Mord vielleicht
passiert ist. Also es ist doch ein
Mord. Das weiss man, also
Vielen Dank. sich. Ja, guck mal, das ist 20 Stunden drin. Ja, die haben jetzt den Ort rausgefunden, wo der Mord vielleicht passiert ist. Also es ist doch ein Mord. Ja, das weiss man eh. Also, das ist das Tolle an dem Podcast, dass es eben noch nicht so dass es noch nicht so ganz klar ist, ob überhaupt irgendwas passiert ist. Und bei dem Podcast wirklich jede fucking Folge Mord verhindert, der ist im Knast, Mord verhindert, nächster Typ im Knast, das FBI steigt ein, macht mit. Richtig geil, kann ich nur empfehlen, ein Podcast, wo sehr viel passiert, The Kill List. Mir kam jetzt nur, als du gesagt hast, Kill List, kam mir eine gute Idee, wie man Geld verdienen könnte. Auftragsmorde. Umgedreht. Man tut so, als wäre man eine Website für Auftragsmorde. Man macht eine Kill List und schreibt da hundert Namen drauf und sagt, Leute, hier ist die Liste, die du kennst, die werden im Laufe des nächsten Jahres getötet werden. Ja. Es sei denn, ihr zahlt uns Geld, um euch von der Liste nehmen zu lassen. So, und dann kriegen hundert Leute, kriegen eine Mail, direkt Spamordner, ohne Umwege, die nicht mal am Vierten da vorbeikommt, direkt Spam-Ordner, da ist es, oh, Entschuldigung, das ist dann so vom FBI, die Liste kann ja echt sein. Und ich meine, das ist... Wie, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, die Liste kann echt sein? Die Liste kann ja echt sein. Wie, as opposed to what? Hä? Aber hat dann das FBI nicht die Verantwortung, die Leute zu kontaktieren? Wenn, hey, im Darknet ist ihr Name gelistet als Killist. Und dann steht das FBI vor deiner Tür und sagt, wir wollten ihr nur mitteilen, ihr Name steht auf der Liste. Und dann kriegst du von hundert Leuten mindestens fünf, die tatsächlich Geld überreisen. Meine Business-Idee war jetzt eher, so eine Website aufzumachen. Weil du raubst Menschen aus, die viel zu viel Geld haben und furchtbare Arschlöcher sind, weil Mordabsicht haben. Die nimmst du aus, du scamst die Schlimmsten der Schlimmen. Also wer ist bereit, 30.000 Euro zu haben, die haben eh zu viel Geld. Das denke ich mir, unabhängig von allen moralischen Fragen. Das ist denen halt wert, ja gut, ja. Nee, nee, das waren alles superreiche.
Findest du es denn moralisch verwerflicher,
einen Auftragsmörder zu engagieren, als selbst zu morden?
Ach so, und dann kannst du die Liste auch noch an die FBI geben und sagen,
ey übrigens, das heißt, du kommst ganz viel hinter Gittern und du hast denen vorher noch 20.000 Euro abgeluchst,
ist eigentlich das beste Businessmodell.
Und da habe ich mich gefragt, warum haben nicht, sind nicht alle,
warum machen nicht.
Na, aber du machst die schon auch Strafbar, oder?
Ich würde doch als Geheimdienst oder FBI-artige Organisation, würde ich doch 50 von solchen Websites aufmachen. Ja. Kauf bei uns Drogen, kauf bei uns bla bla bla, kauf bei uns Auftragsmorde. Ja. Und dann das ganze Geld nehmen, an den Staat geben, hier, baut Schulen. Geht das so einfach? Baut Schulen davon, macht was auch immer. Wo kommt das Geld her? Erstmal bauen wir uns eine geile Zentrale. Wo kommt das Geld her? Erst mal bauen wir uns eine richtig geile FBI-Deutschland-Zentrale. Das fällt nicht auf. Der Pendant-Zentrale. FBI-Dortmund, ja. Ja, okay. Ich weiß nicht, ob ... Ja, okay. Kann man von Dieben und ... Also wie unmoralisch müssen Leute sein, damit man Anspruch hat auf deren Geld? Das ist, glaube ich, meine Frage. Genau, die Frage ist unmoralischer zu morden. Ich glaube, gesetzlich, der Gesetzestext ist ja klar, glaube ich. Gut, du hast, ja, und ich soll jetzt sagen, wie er ist, weil, nee, das ist ja gleich bewertet, ja.
Nee.
Na klar, natürlich, Auftrag und Tat ist gleich. Verschwörung zum Mord ist, glaube ich ... Der Versuch ... Nee, nee, nee. Da muss man mal Studien lesen. Auch wenn du da jetzt vielleicht tiefer im Gesetzestext drin bist, glaube ich, der Richter ist ja befangen. Wenn du den Abzug gedrückt hast, wirst du mit Sicherheit anders belangt, als wenn du jemanden beauftragt hast. Weil du kannst ja immer noch denken, ja, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Scam. Du kannst, da ist ja viel mehr dazwischen. Ja, aber der Versuch ist strafbar und auch das Auftragen ist auch strafbar. Natürlich ist es strafbar. Egal eine Frage. Ja, aber genau so. Nein. Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Wird aber, jetzt mal unabhängig vom juristischen Gesetzestext, den wir hier immer hochhalten und so ehrenvoll. Du hast den Hervorgerungen. Aber wie siehst du das denn moralisch? Also ist es für dich moralisch das Gleiche oder sagst du vielleicht, ist es sogar besser, wenn man es nicht selber macht oder schlimmer, wenn man es nicht selber macht? Sollte man das schlechte Gewissen dann auch tragen als Strafe, wenn man es selber macht und sich davor nicht wegstehen? Das hast du ja auch, wenn jemand durch deine Überweisung umgekommen ist. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht so stark. Du hast nicht diese dramatischen Bilder, wie du selber jemanden erwirkst oder so. Das ist ja ... Ja, gut, jetzt müssen wir hier die großen Fragen antworten. Ich würde schon sagen, es ist unmoralisch, selber zu morden. Aber man sollte es gleich bestrafen. Okay. Mord ist Mord. Ob durch Überweisungen, du kannst auch durch Überweisungen Menschen umbringen. Das ist doch ein guter Folgenditel auch. Geld tötet. Du kannst auch durch Überweisungen nehmen. Capitalism kills. Ja, okay. Nee, ja, du halt eher. Also warum jetzt Capitalism? Du hast ja den Auftrag gegeben. Hier steht ja,, bringt sie um. Auch wegen dieser gesprochenen Alteration. Ja, ja, ja, ich verstehe das schon. Ja, aber okay, gut. Dachte ich eigentlich schon, dass das im Darknet geht, ne? Also ich meine, also angenommen, du bist Mörder, so. Wo bietest du denn deine Dienste-File? Also Craigslist oder wo gehst du hin? Ich glaube, dass bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen unter einem, also wenn man, if you know, you know, you know, also wenn du, du musst halt unter einer Metapher. Also das ist diese, du verkaufst Rollladen bei, oder Teppich, ich bin Teppichhändler bei Kleinanzeigen. Ja, verstehe und dann, okay, Teppich und das Und das FBI kennt diese Metapher nicht und diesen Code nicht. Aber wie erfährst du über diesen Code als Kunde? Und was passiert, wenn du einfach literally einen Teppich kaufen? Richtig. Ich würde gerne einen Teppich bei Ihnen kaufen. Und dann sagt er, okay, für wen denn? Für wen wollen Sie den Teppich? Für mich und meine Frau. Für mich und meine Frau und den Kleinen. Genau. Ja, wir sind immer donnerstags abends da, da können Sie gerne vorbeikommen. Okay, und er sagt, okay, das machen wir 20.000. Wow, das muss ein toller Teppich sein. Aber ich finde den mega, den Teppich. Und meine Frau, weiß ich auch, dass die den lieben würde. Und wir haben ja gerade wegen diesem Versicherungsfall mit diesen Energydrinks, wo meiner Frau schlecht geworden ist, da haben wir ja Hunderttausend bekommen, Schmerzensgeld, auch wegen der Schwangerschaft und so. Genau. Weil wir gar nicht wussten, dass es Energydrinks waren. Und dann, das ist jetzt gar nicht so wichtig. Aber sagen wir mal so, wir können uns was gönnen und dann nehmen wir uns den Teppich. Peng! Ja, das ist ganz ... Was bringen Sie meine Frau um? Das wäre der Satz, was bringen Sie meine Frau um?
Was bringen Sie denn hier so meine Frau um?
Ja, aber ich fand das, ich fand es fantastisch, weil, stell dir mal vor, du kommst auf so eine Liste, weil er ist auch so awkward wie wir im Sinne von, er ruft nicht so gerne Leute an.
Oh ja.
Und dann, es ist ja, ich stell dir das ja vor wie, du musst eine Pizza bestellen.
Ja.
Also, ähnlich schlimm.
Du musst jemanden anrufen und
sagen, ja, im Darknet ist ihr Name aufgetaucht.
Vielleicht will sie jemanden töten.
Hm.
Uneingenehmer Call.
Aber gibt's gar keinen Auftraggeber dann, oder zumindest
so ein Nickname oder so, weil du kannst ja dann so
Rose Bunny und so, ah ja ja,
okay, das ist mein alter Mitbewohner. Du siehst immer die Nicknames.
Ja, ja.
Nimmt man sich einen komplett neuen Nickname für Darkweb?
Wahrscheinlich schon, ne? Wirklich.
Okay, die Leute sind dann doch ein bisschen
Vielen Dank. okay, das ist mein alter Mitbewohner. Du siehst immer die Nicknames. Nimmt man sich einen komplett neuen Nickname für Stargrab? Das wurden sich immer komplett neue Nicknames genommen. Wirklich? Okay, die Leute sind dann doch ein bisschen bereit, dazuzulernen und nicht irgendwie den guten alten Tongsmas Tongsmas 91 dann zu nehmen, mit dem ich früher schon im Filmfehlerforum aktiv war. Tongsmas. So, da ist man dann vielleicht ein Stück weiter, wenn man eine Recherche hat. Filmfehler Forum Florentin.
Ja, da war ich sehr aktiv.
Da habe ich jeden Film auseinandergenommen.
Das war eine wilde Zeit.
Welcher Film hat so richtig sein Fett wegbekommen?
Na gut, die Filme, die ich viel geschaut habe, der Ringe natürlich, da habe ich ein paar Kameras gesehen,
an manchen Stellen.
Was war der schlimmste Film,
der schlechteste Film, den du in den letzten Wochen geguckt hast?
Oh, ich schaue tatsächlich ... The most recent bad film. Ja, ich bin da ... Ich schau da immer nur so kurz blickwinklig rein. Ich wollte jetzt noch mal The Batman sehen, den aktuellen Batman, The Batman. Ja, ja. Aber so schlecht fand ich den jetzt auch nicht. Ich glaube, wenn ich den richtig schlecht filmen ... Ich glaube, ich schaue in letzter Zeit nur noch Filme, die ich wirklich schon kenne, so. Ich habe so gute Laune-Filme auf der Festplatte irgendwie. Ich bin auch gar nicht mehr online. Ich habe Under the Silver Lake gesehen. Super. Andrew Garfield, so eine richtig, ich liebe das so, wenn du nachts im Zug bist, 23 Uhr, dunkel, müde, schluffig und dann Under the Silver Lake. Ach, traumhaft. So richtig so eine müde, transzendente, schläfrige Stimmung ist der perfekte Film. Toller Film mag ich, äh, weirder Film. Sehr weirder Film, aber gefällt mir auch richtig gut. Und da gibt es heute noch Fan-Zirkel, die versuchen, da geheime Botschaften zu entschlüsseln, weil im Film geht es sehr viel um geheime Botschaften. Verschwörungstheorien und Botschaften, die in den Massenmedien transportiert werden und so. Und da gibt es heute noch Leute, die denken, dass der Film noch nicht ganz geknackt ist und dass da noch Geheimnisse drin sind, was ich mir gut vorstellen kann. Aber letzten Endes ist es vielleicht auch nichts, kann man natürlich auch so interpretieren. Jetzt kam er neulich so ein Typ Forward, der gesagt hat, mein Opa war der Zodiac Killer. Wirklich? Ja. Und ist der Opa schon tot oder ist es dann so ein ... Okay. Und aber im Moment des Todes hat er das sofort gesagt oder Jahre später? Nee, nee, hat er was nicht gesagt. Aber er setzt eins und eins zusammen. Er hat selber ermittelt. Ja, es gibt ja diese berühmten Rechtschreibfehler bei Until, hat der Zodiac Killer das mit zwei L geschrieben.
Oder mit einem, ich weiß ja mich selber nicht genau.
Weil mir passiert ja immer dieser doofe Fehler, dass ich Until …
Moment mal, Stefan, ja, wo warst du in den 80ern?
Noch nicht am Leben.
Ah, okay. Glück gehabt.
Noch nicht hier in Deutschland am Leben, sondern in San Francisco. Snitch oder Snitch, oder? Cooler Claim, finde ich. Cooler Claim. Mein Opa ist der Zodiac Killer. Ja. Ja, aber hat er auch klare Beweise dafür? Ich meine, für Deutsche sehr unbeeindruckend. Ja, ja, mein Vater ist Fritzl, so das ist ... Weil die Opas hier zunande ...
Ja, gut, ist ...
Naja, na ja, klar.
Niemand hier reißt wirklich die Augen auf, wenn der sagt,
mein Opa war der Zodiac-Killer, der hat 13 Leute umgebracht.
Dann sagen wir alle ...
Ja, Angeber.
Ja, krass, krass, krass, krass, krass, krass.
Krass, krass, das ist viel. Ja, ja. Nee, aber ich fand es einen spannenden Claim. Ist natürlich was anderes. Naja, aber glaubst du dem Ganzen? Bist du tief drin im Zodiac-Case? Also hast du da eine Einschätzung dafür? Ich habe recherchiert, einen Film geguckt. Ja, den habe ich auch geguckt. Ja, klar, Fincher, ja. Zodiac, Fincher finde ich einen Superfilm. Ja. Einer meiner absoluten Lieblingsfilme tatsächlich. Und da habe ich recherchiert. Robert Downey Jr. Und gedacht, ja, und Jake Rillen-Hall. Ja, Rillen-Hall. Und habe gedacht, ja, der ist super, der Film. Und dann, aber weiter bin ich nicht gekommen. Okay, alles klar, da hat dann deine Ermittlungen aufgehört. Aufgehört beim Verdict, dass der Film gut ist. Ja. Generell, es ist Oktober. Ihr seid dann von uns gewohnt, dass ihr Horrorfilm-Tipps bekommt. Gruseltober ist eigentlich immer noch im Laufen. Hast du dich schon intensiv gegruselt diesen Oktober? Nein, ich war ja an der Ostsee, da alleine gucke ich keine Gruselfilme. Wäre aber ein guter Ort gewesen. Du warst unter Wassergrusel. Du, ich war nicht auf der Ostsee. Ich war auch nicht in der Ostsee, ich war an der Ostsee.
An der Ostsee, bei der Ostsee.
Ich habe geguckt Barbarian.
Toller Film.
Moment, ist das nicht eine Serie, wo die Latein reden?
Nein, nein, nein, das ist Barbarians.
Das ist The Barbarians.
The Barbarians, The Barbarians.
Nee, wir reden von Barbarians.
Der Film.
Ach Gott, deine Filmempfehlungen sind immer so kompliziert ist er komplizierend? Es ist so schwierig zu schreiben. Barbarian. Von Zack Kregger. Ja. Und gruselig hast du dir richtig die Decke über den Kopf gezogen? Da habe ich mir wirklich einen weggegruselt, ordentlich. Also da habe ich mir die Seele aus dem Leib geschrieben. Der war sehr gruselig, gilt für mich, gilt von mir. Fünf von fünf Kürbissen? Vier von fünf Fingerklemmen. Oh, okay. Was sind das Foltermittel aus dem Mittelalter? Streckbänke oder irgendwie sowas? Sechs von sieben Streckbänken gibt es für mich von mir an Barbarian. Toller Film. Wirklich super, super Film. Mochte ich sehr. Stark. Absolut stark. Ja, ich bin noch nicht so richtig im Gruselfieber, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Vielleicht erst gegen Ende. Empfiehlt wieder It Follows, wieder das dritte Jahr in Folge. Ich kann leider wirklich nur It Follows sehen. Selbst wenn man den Jumpscare erwartet, erschreckt man sich trotzdem noch. Wenn man denkt, ah, wann kommt er, wo ist er? A, ah, hat man einfach immer noch drin. Genau, von daher.
Ich bin ja auch bei gruseligen Instagram-Reels mittlerweile auch angekommen, habe ich wieder ein bisschen einen schönen Algorithmus gespült bekommen, da wo die so die Leute verzerren und dann gibt es so einen Typen, der macht immer so diese gruseligen Instagram-Videos, sodass ich sein Haus auch schon kenne. Ich kenne einfach das Haus, ich kenne die Ecken, ich weiss genau, und er macht das dann immer so gruselig mit runter zum Keller,
Kellertreppe, ist da nix
und dann wieder weg und dann wieder hin und dann ist da ganz kurz
was und ist immer das Gleiche und ich
schaue das so mit angewinkelten Display so
nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
so schaue ich das auch die ganze Zeit.
Aus dem Ruhabteil.
Nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein,
nein, nein, swipe und nächste, ah, zum Glück wieder ein Baby, das wehgetan wird. Katzenvideos. Zum Glück wieder ein Katzenvideos, wo ein Baby einer Katze wehtut und dann wird die Katze dem Baby weh. Und beisst das Baby in den Arm. Das ist immer wirklich niedlich, wie die da runterrollen, wie die durch die Gegend rollen einfach die ganze Zeit. Babys sind witzig, wenn man Babys den wehgetan würde, die irgendwie umfallen oder wo jemand da ist, das ist immer herrlich. Ja, weil die fallen ja immer weich, denke ich, auf so dicke Hintern mit den dicken Windeln. Ja, dicken Windeln primär auch als Abfederung so, dass die dann da sind. Aber ich mag gerne so Videos, wo so das ältere Kind haut so mit einem Pinata auf die Pinata und dann die anderen Kinder checken das Spiel nicht so ganz und dann irgendwann geht die Pinata kaputt und alle anderen Kinder denken, uh, jetzt ist es vorbei, rennen auf die Pinata zu, aber das Kind, das den Schläger hat, hat es ja gar nicht gesehen und schlägt weiter um sich und mäht einfach die anderen Kinder. Das ist insane. Wer hat gedacht, dass Pinata eine gute Idee ist? Das ist so amerikanisch. Gib einem kleinen Kind einen langen Holzstock und verbind die Augen. Und das Kind soll um sich herumschlagen. Ich habe eine Idee, ich habe eine Idee, ich habe eine Idee. Wir geben diesem kleinen Kind einen Holzstock und es schlägt auf blind, wir verbinden die Augen und es schlägt blind um sich. Es schlägt blind um sich. Aber woher soll es wissen, dass ... Und es weiß es nicht. Alle Kinder streben drumrum, das Kind schlägt um sich. Vorn sind Nägel, am Holz sind Nägel. Aber ich finde das auch ein gutes Video, das man gut faken könnte, wo dann das Kind wirklich so die anderen Kinder ummäht und dann kommen die Eltern, wollen es aufhalten und es haut auch die Eltern einfach um, wirklich wie so ein Jedi-Kampf. Und dann die Kamera dreht um das Kind und du siehst, die Brinde ist verrutscht und es sieht eigentlich. Ja, genau. Ja, und dann dreht sich das Kind so um und guckt in die Kamera. Und haut den Kameramann. Und cut. Und dann so holgt aus und dann cut, harter cut.
Abspann. Und das ist mir nicht so, Jesus Christ,
das war eine Production-Veli, ganz schön hart.
Olivia wurde nie wieder gesehen. Für so ein
Instagram-Reel. Und du so
Halt, Halt, Halt!
Ja, aber könnte man gut machen.
Ist das eine gute Idee? Hast du jemals,
ich meine, das lame
deutsche Äquivalent ist ja der
Schwanz an Esel,
wo du dem Esel den Schwanz anstecken musst. Kenn kenne ich nur aus Filmen. Das kenne ich auch nur aus Filmen irgendwie, aber irgendwie hast du so einen Schwanz mit einem Nagel und musstest dem Esel anstecken. Ja, aber auch spitzer Gegenstand. Also irgendwie will man Kinder brennen sehen. Aber es ist so wirklich so, nochmal drei Stufen runter von Pinata schlagen. Nee, weißt du, was das deutsche Äquivalent ist? Top schlagen. Suppenlöffel in der Hand, was soll schief gehen? Und auch da wurden Fingerchen geklecht. Und das Kind stampft einfach auf Opa zu und Opa kommt nicht schnell genug weg und das Kind einfach bam, bam, bam, die Einschläge kommen näher und Opa versucht, vom Stuhl aufzustehen, kommt nicht so schnell weg. Opa, nein, kommt nicht so hoch weg, nicht so schnell weg, kann nicht schnell aufstehen. Opa ist so schnell aufgestanden. Ja, aber es ist nur ein Suppenlöffel. Ja, aber auch der, wirklich mit genug Ehrgeiz geschwungen, kann ganz schöne Bessuren. Ja, aber so die mexikanischen Kinder oder amerikanischen Kinder haben alle so einen fucking Baseballschläger in der Hand, so metallend und hauen einfach drumrum und alle sind super nah. Das ist so seltsam. Ja, es ist fantastisch. Es ist fantastisch. Aber naja, musst du auch machen, das ist eine Lektion. Um sich danach Massen von Zuckerdinger, die da in der Pinata drin waren, sich reinzudontern. Wo ich sage, ist Zucker nicht sogar noch gefährlicher als der Baseballspieler? Okay, alles klar. Wir hören hier auf, das wird mit zu pädagogisch, das ist nicht mehr mein Podcast-UFO. Nee, ist Zucker nicht noch schlimmer? Ich muss mich jetzt eine Woche erholen. Zucker, töten. Nein, ich breche hier ab. Das ist mein eines Veto. Als wir im Podcast gestartet haben, haben wir gesagt, jeder von uns hat ein Veto, wo man den Podcast unterbrechen kann. Und an dieser Stelle ziehe ich mein Veto, ich drücke den Veto-Knopf. Ist Zucker nicht die schlimmste Droge? Und ich sage, wir heben ab an der Stelle und ich setze das durch mit meinem Beto. Stefan, Tietze, steig ein jetzt, komm rein, steig ein jetzt. Ich stehe noch so beleidigt. Stefan, wir müssen los. Stefan, du kommst jetzt rein. Stefan, du kommst jetzt rein. Ich zähl bis drei. Stefan, du kommst jetzt rein, ich zähl bis fünf. Okay, was dann? Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, okay, ich laufe, ich laufe, ich laufe rein. Und wir heben ab.